What's going on? Alan Drau here and in
today's video, I'm going to be giving
you eight copywriting exercises to
instantly up your copy game. Now, who am
I? Well, I've been around the block for
a little bit. I've been writing copy for
about 4 years. I've built my own email
list where I've sold well over multiple
six figures selling my own products for
my own business, for my own list. Not
only that, but I've sold over a million
dollars worth of products using my copy
via email for my clients for the past
couple years. In fact, my first 30,000
royalty check came in my first 6 months
of writing copy. And that is because I
practiced the things in the videos that
I'm going to show you today so that you
can do the same thing, make more money,
buy freedom in your copywriting
business, and be hella good. So, I'm
excited. I'm ready to dive in. If you're
ready to dive in, actually, before we
dive in, I have a gift for you, the
copywriter. If you hit the link in the
description below, I have 63 cash cow
copywriting tips for free that I'm going
to gift you. All you got to do is put
your email in and I'll instantly send
you copywriting catalyst. Going to give
you 63 fantastic tips beyond what I'm
going to tell you in this video. But
that's free. That's just for you. Let's
dive into the video. Make sure to stick
around for the entire video because I'm
going to give you the best copywriting
exercise last. So stick around. All
right, copywriting exercise number one,
and that is read an ad a day. The best
way to get good at copywriting is to
read great copy. Very simple. One of my
favorite ways to do this is by
subscribing to great copywriters
newsletters. So I like to subscribe to
Ben Settle, Chris Forsakowski, Laura
Belgray, Kevin Rogers, Daniel Thrussell,
guys like this, really good copywriters.
And you can find really good copywriters
in any niche. Subscribe to their
newsletter and just read an email a day.
I typically do this with a cup of coffee
in the morning and it just teaches your
mind to understand what great copy reads
and looks like. This develops your taste
for great copy, which is uncopy
pasteable by AI. You must have great
taste to write great copy. Another way
you can do this is you can go to a
website called swiped.co
and download sales letters from people
like Gary Ben Svena, David Oglevie,
Frank Kern. There's a bunch of stuff up
there. You can download great sales
letters, read great sales letters. Even
if you don't know what you're looking
for, it doesn't matter. You're just
developing the taste for what great copy
smells, feels, and looks like.
Copywriting exercise number two is to
handcopy great ads. So let's say that
you're reading those emails from Ben
Settle and Daniel Dasel, Chris
Ozakowski, or that you downloaded some
sales letters from swipe.co. You can
handcopy those sales letters. This is a
tip from Gary Halper in his book, The
Boron Letters. When you hand copy great
copy, your mind and your muscles absorb
that copy significantly deeper than as
if you were just to read it because you
slow down and you start noticing the
nuances and the power words that they
use, the transitions from sentence to
sentence and those things become
ingrained in you. Therefore, they start
to seep out of you when you write great
copy. Set aside 10, 15 minutes in the
morning, get a journal like this one and
just hand copy things. Even just
handcopying the bullets, you can get
really good really fast. Copywriting
exercise number three is compete with
the immortals. This is a line from the
famous copywriter Gary Benga. Gary Benga
has beaten the most control packages out
of any other living copywriter ever,
which means he beat the best of the best
ads ever, the most times. And his tip on
how he does that is by competing with
the immortals. Basically, what he did
was he took the best ads in the world
and then said, "How can I rewrite this
to make it better?" That's like going on
the basketball court and saying, "How
could I beat Michael Jordan?" Well,
that's a pretty big feat to try and
figure out, but that's what you as a
copywriter do. So, you go find the best
sales letters ever on swipe.co co or the
best emails, those emails that you're
reading, and you would say, "How would I
make this better?" So, when you're
handcopying that John Carlton sales
letter, that Ben Settle email, you would
start to think and say, "How could I
rewrite this?" And then go do it. Go
rewrite that email to make it better. Go
rewrite that headline on that sales
letter to make it better. Exercise
number four is keep your own swipe file.
Now, I am primarily an email copyriter.
99.9% of the copy that I write is
emails. And every once in a while, I
write some sales letters. But for an
email copywriter like myself, I like to
keep a swipe file in my Gmail. So, just
in my Gmail, I actually have a folder
that says swipe file. And every time
that I write an email that either makes
me buy something or that I just think is
amazing copy, I move that email over to
my swipe file folder. And so, what this
does is it builds a collection of the
best email copy that I could possibly
read. And the purpose of this swipe file
is it actually curates your taste
because there's a lot of crap out there.
And so what you want is you want one big
folder of the best of the best. And you
want to accumulate your mindset to
understand what is the best copy and
what isn't the best copy. Exercise
number five is keep a field notes with
you at all times. this dandy little
thing. You could buy a pack of three on
Amazon for like 12 bucks. And it's just
empty paper with a pen that I keep with
me at all times to write all of my ideas
down. Because your best copywriting
ideas will not be when you're sitting in
front of a blue light screen just trying
to scratch your head and think of ideas.
No, it'll actually be when you're taking
a walk or when you're having lunch or
when you're playing with your kids or
when you're just sitting down trying to
relax and read a book. That's when all
your best ideas are going to come
because that is called incubation. Okay?
Your mind is at ease. Your mind is at
rest and it finally has the capacity to
sit there and think and ponder and
wonder. That is when your best ideas
come, which means you can then whip out
your little field notes and and start
writing those best ideas down. So that
way when you go back into work mode, you
don't forget your best stuff. Now, I
know what you're thinking, Alan. I could
just write it in my phone. Don't do that
because what actually ends up happening
is you go into a distraction dark hole
and you open up Twitter, you open up
Instagram, you check your email notific,
and boom, your idea is gone. And that's
what this lets you do. It lets you just
explore the idea. Just kind of float
around, write some stuff down. You have
no obligation to write the entire email
or the sales letter or the copyright
now. You're just getting the idea on
paper. And then when you're ready to
work on it, you can sit down at your
computer, at your typewriter, at your
laptop, and you can finish the idea
there. Copywriting exercise number six
is to read your copy out loud. This is
the simplest thing that will make your
copy sound more conversational because
copywriting is nothing more than a
one-on-one conversation
multiplied. Okay, pretend that you are a
doortodoor salesman. You're knocking on
someone's door and you're trying to sell
a product. Well, you are one human
talking to another human, except you're
doing it at a level of one to one. Okay?
Copywriting is the same thing, but
you're doing it on a level of one to a
million, one to a thousand, whatever it
is. You are basically knocking on
millions of people's doors and you are
handing them a letter and you're saying,
"Hey, read this." But it's still a
conversation. And in that tone, you
wouldn't walk to somebody's door and
start talking to them in some robotic
dry voice. If you want to instantly
solve this problem at hyper speed or
whatever the crap that chat GBT is
pumping out that you guys are copy and
pasting, it doesn't work. Okay? But when
you read your copy out loud, you start
to find all those little robotic dry
spots as well as the lumps and bumps in
your copy where it doesn't read near as
smooth because you stumble over your
words as you're reading them out loud.
So reading your copy out loud is a dead
giveaway of what's conversational and
what's boring, dry, or unnecessary. And
copywriting exercise number seven, my
favorite, the best. If you don't do
anything in this video, but you do this,
you will be top 5% in less than 18
months. That I can almost guarantee. And
that is the copyrightiting exercise that
I call the infinity loop. Okay? If
you've ever seen an infinity loop, it's
two loops, okay? And it goes back and
forth and back and forth. Okay? The
infinity loop copywriting practice is
something that I've instilled for the
last two years every single day without
fail. And what it is is actually let me
just show you why books. We're going to
grab a book like cash advertising. Okay?
And in cash advertising it gives you 100
secrets of ad agency psychology to make
big money selling anything to anyone.
Okay? So 100 secrets. But what it is is
it's loaded with tips. You see how many
tips and highlights and all these things
that I have. And basically all I want to
do is find one tip, one lesson and and
that's that's what I'm doing at first
and then I want to implement it into
copy immediately. Okay, so it's lesson
implement lesson implement. That's the
infinity loop. Okay, you get a lesson
and then you implement it. Okay, here's
the way that that would work. Okay,
let's say that you're like me and you
write a daily email. This is the best
way to implement copywriting exercises
every day is to write a daily email
because every day you're on the hook to
write copy. And so as a daily email
copywriter, you create an opportunity to
practice lesson implement every single
day, the infinity loop. And so I'll come
in here. Here's a lesson from cash
advertising. Fear sells. It motivates.
It urges. And it moves people to action.
And it drives them to spend money. So
use fear to sell. Okay. So now that's a
lesson where I say, "Okay, how do I use
fear?" Not in a manipulative way, but in
a sales way where now I could take that
lesson from this book and implement it
into an email. I'm not trying to read 10
pages of this book, 20 pages. I'm not
doing anything but taking that one
lesson that I learned and I'm
implementing it. Remember, learn,
implement, learn, implement. So now I
take that lesson and I'm going to write
an email. I'm going to pick up this
keyboard and I'm going to write an email
that thinks okay how would I use fear to
sell. That is the infinity loop. And
then the next day you read through the
next page of cash advertising or very
good copy or David Olggov any of these
very good copy the ade copyrightiting
handbook copyright Olgo on advertising.
This will cost you $100 to get this and
this is all the wisdom you need for the
rest of your life on copyrightiting.
Okay, that wraps us up. Those are the
seven copywriting exercise that will
instantly up your game. And if you like
that, please like and subscribe to the
channel. It means the world to me. It
tells me that you found this content
valuable and that you want me to help
you become the best copywriter that you
could be so you can make a lot of money,
buy your freedom, and enjoy your
freaking life. If that sounds good to
you, again, stick around, watch more
videos, go down the rabbit hole. I
appreciate everything that you do, and I
will catch you on the next one. Here's
an intimate moment between me and you
where I'm going to tell you one more
time. If you could just click the link
in the description below, okay? Just
click it. Just go ahead and click it.
It's a free gift. Doesn't love free
gifts. You get down in there, you click
it, you put your name in, put your
email. That's all I'm asking. Name and
email. Okay? And I'm gifting you
something. That's incredible, right?
It's incredible. It's the best gift
you've gotten today. I guarantee that.
Okay? It's the best gift you've gotten
today. And unless unless you got like a
Rolex today, then that's that's probably
the best gift you got. But if not, this
is definitely the best gift you've got.
You're going to put your email in.
That's going to be a wonderful time.
You're going to love it. And I'm
instantly going to help you up your game
even more beyond this video. That's
incredible, right? I mean, that's that's
that's beyond generous if we're being
honest. Beyond generous. I don't know
anybody else doing this. I mean, as as
well as I'm doing it, but anywh who Anyh
who, go ahead, grab the gift. Enjoy. All
right. It's yours. All yours. See youall
next time.